Well, good morning church.
We're so glad you are here to worship with us,
and we're gonna begin our time together, uh, by, um,
celebrating with Annie, uh, her baptism
and her community group leader.
Danielle is gonna read her story for us today.
I grew up in a Christian household,
but I never really wanted to go to church or found it fun.
Ever since I was little, I have struggled with anger
and growing up with the anger turned into
mental health problems.
In middle school, my mental health got worse
and middle school was just rough
and it was rough time without the Lord.
I started struggling a lot with depression and anxiety
and a lot of the time I just didn't want to be alive.
I had tried to end my life one night,
but then I saw my Bible and started crying.
I immediately picked it up
and the first verse I saw was Psalm six, eight through nine.
Those verses were something I really needed to hear
and I started praying.
I asked God to save me.
I felt so much peace after I prayed
and I just sat on the floor crying.
It felt like he was with me.
This summer I went to Canuck and I repented of my sins
and I gave my life to Jesus.
I immediately started crying, not because I was sad, but
because of how happy and relieved I felt.
And during kids camp, I realized
how much I wasn't really living for the Lord.
So I prayed to really change my ways.
I have decided today to get baptized
to publicly show my love for Jesus to you,
and that he's my Lord.
He has saved me from death to life.
Annie, we're proud of you.
I have seen how the Lord has transformed your life
and we praise God for his work in you.
It's my privilege to baptize you, my sister, in the name
of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Let's worship today.
Let's stand to our.